e
si vous m'aviez pas prévenus pour le
tournage on devait se voir tous les deux
vous attends attends là mais attends
j'ai dit bonjour je suis jean daniel
youtube le patron de youtube ça fait des
années qu'on sait pas vus lus n'est ce
pas il se trouve que la plateforme
comporte la nouveauté je vous les
présente suivez moi dans cette partie
mais aussi en
grandissant j'ai validé suivez-moi
youtube est un puits sans fond de
connaissances je mets un point d'honneur
à encourager les contenus informatifs
jeunes dans sa créatrice au tout début
de la seconde guerre mondiale où là les
annonceurs sont pas aimé ça ah non mais
ya pas un seul mot sensible si là vous
allez parler du mot interdit la maman je
dis pas un seul mot sur les nazis perdu
bedimo
va chercher faut que je vous parle
absolument d'une nouvelle catégorie de
vidéos qui cartonne sur deux plateformes
je parle bien évidement pop
plus jamais je rentre dedans d'ailleurs
et comme je vous parle absolument hors
jeu nicolas sarkozy au nom une pub grand
plaisir de vous lire le temps des
tempêtes ça se serait jamais arrivé avec
tubes premium
dix ans plus tard à ma formation
spéciale de pub 900 euros par mois en
pizzas pâtes chanson avec youtube
premium profiter de vos créateurs
préférés sans aucune publicité je sais
pas si vous avez remarqué mais il ya
plein de vieux sur facebook et c'est la
capote pub c'est pas mal cette vidéo a
pu être possible grâce à north vpn
cassano revue pn vous pouvez protéger
vos données mais aussi changer votre
localisation pour accéder à d'autres
contenus sur des plateformes vidéo
pendant une période très jolies filles
vous pouvez profiter d'un abonnement de
deux ans à prix réduits en vous rendant
sur north vpn points comme cela cyprien
cliquez sur le lien dans la description
profitez-en c'est sans risque grâce à la
garantie de remboursement pendant 30
jours mais vous êtes de mèche en fait
peut-être nous deux mais grande fierté
chez youtube ce sont les co oui mais on
peut finir là
j'espère se vendent bien et maintenant
il faut que je vous parle du jeu vidéo
le gaming c'est l'adn même de youtube
ils sont voilà justement je vous disais
il ya plus grand monde ici
ah voilà un gamer ah non moi je reste
pas du tout moi je dépose mes vod et je
retourne sur twitter je repars déjà non
mais fait un petit l'exploit non j'ai un
train de live qui m'attend je suis
désolé si tu as après ils n'hésitent pas
à ta bonne et bien sûr mettez lui un bon
gros pouce rouge ce petit con mais y'a
plus les pouces rouge vous avez demandé
les enlever
ça me fait penser que dans notre entre
vous pouvez pas aller par là monsieur
non plus vous pouvez pas les paroles
[ __ ] mais c'est ma voix comme jeu
parce que je veux m'en bouffe est cher
attendez
d'habitude on va passer s'il me fait pas
chez hockey
mais je connais ou
youtube c'est sa joie des grands et des
petits
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce bordel mais chez tic tac
monsieur ils ont racheté l'immeuble
sictom et n'importe quoi j'ai jamais
validé sa vont plier bagage n'importe
quoi non monsieur sabine vous faites ce
que je dis elle laisse à mon nom c'est
pas nsa et celle de les jours on
travaille ensemble ça fait des semaines
que c'est de vous donner ma démission à
chaque fois que je vais vous parler vous
envoyer balader comme une merde désolé
je voulais pas en arriver là mais là
j'ai pu le choix
partie vanessa quel plaisir de vous voir
choix ils vont commencer demain
le patron de tik tok mon nouvel
employeur chanter je vous ai déjà vu les
gens daniel c'est ça on sait déjà entrés
oui j'étais in music de rihanna plus de
trois secondes dans ma vidéo et elle a
été supprimée
plus jamais tu utilises une musique on
tape à l'oeil droit vous savez j'ai tik
tok enlaçant à rédéné vos talents lever
une nouvelle tendance un tout nouvel
algorithme aussi c'est incroyable je
vous faire vis des vallées juste après
moi
salut patron salua oui on est sur toutes
les nouvelles tendances bah moi aussi
car massa qu'est ce t'en penses ouais
bah l'attend
[Musique]
coup
c'est le tictoc gendarmes
[Musique]
jamais tu fais ça toi
bon maintenant on va par là et non par
la musique fait partie intégrante de tik
tok ouais bah moi aussi sur youtube que
j'ai tous les clips les musiques à la
mode oui mais nous on peut les
réutiliser
pointe des mots comme ça jean daniel
gros douleur on s'exprime comme ça sur
tic tac
[Musique]
pour le pauvre web au final j'aime bien
quand ils ferment leur gueule
[Musique]
attention la barre bleue ouais non parce
qu'il y en a qui sont restés bloqués
comme ça c'est pas beau à voir
cette mineure au 107 106 curieux
gagner pas mal d'argent ouais moi si on
a fait 50 millions de vues ouais
beaucoup cinq ans c'est bien ça fait
quand même ah oui
n'oubliez pas les deux euros ou
partagèrent vous démerder et puis nous
on garde tout pas con ils se couchent
vous montre le challenge c'est un carton
et les filtres aussi ils sont
incroyables je vous présentais bénin
porte chossy et charlie d'améliorer ses
bons jeux j'en ai assez vu vous fait du
super travail je voudrais pas plus
longtemps
attendez vous portez des jeux
vous allez vous y plaire ici les pleins
de nouveaux contenus des nouveaux
créateurs
des gens à la mode pas comme moi c'est
important d'évoluer c'est bien
il faut souhaite une bonne continuation
pas de ça
perdez pas votre temps avec moi
je me souviens de mon premier jour chez
youtube quoi j'étais trop contente
c'était le plus beau jour de ma vie je
crois et franchement je pense que si
vous n'avez pas créé cette plateforme
est bien tik tok twitch tout ça ça
n'existerait pas
ça fait quinze ans que ça existe 15 ans
c'est énorme ça me paraît tellement loin
vous souvenez pourquoi les peuples voulu
et créé youtube bien sûr
je voulais rapprocher les gens
flic n'importe qui de n'importe où
n'importe quel milieu social puissent
partager une vidéo et la montrer à ses
amis sa famille des inconnus je voulais
casser les barrières
enfin c'est vraiment tout ce que vous
dites
je suit au pis ça
vous savez quoi
là je pense que vous allez avoir besoin
de quelqu'un pour vous aider dans votre
tâche alors je vous suis chez avec vous
je reste avec vous vous pouvez compter
sur moi je dirais eu des chances
quoi on va créer les shorts c'est comme
tik tok mais pareil on va bien [ __ ]
short en jean merci de regarder cette
vidéo et merci nord vpn de l'avoir
sponsorisés je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez profiter de l'offre actuelle en
allant sur north bay peine points comme
saint cyprien vous avez 30 jours de
période d'essai ainsi vous pourrez
changer de localisation pour accéder par
exemple la formule 1 gratuite en
belgique ou à netflix us merci normes et
pn vous soutenez des créateurs comme
nous et ça ça fait très plaisir je vous
dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo